ストレスと怒りって同じものなんですか？ ん？ ストレスと怒りって同じものなんですか？ 同じものです
いっぱいお悩みいますか？ まあ子供もいますね
よくストレス 子供もよくストレス溜まるんです
それはもういろんなことあるんだから嫌でしょうにね
あれやこれやっていうことは怒りなんです
だから子供にはいっぱいストレスあるんです
はい あの 慈しみっていうのはわかるんですけども
わかるっていうか そのわかるって言ったらちょっと語弊があるんですけども
慈しみが一番いい  はっきり具体的な言葉として説明できるのは慈しみだっていうのは異議はないんですけども
その 要するに混乱してる人に対応するっていうのは
一体何を相手に慈しみとして持っていけばいいのかっていうのがわからなくなってしまう
だから 要するに相手が怒っていれば怒りをなだめればいいし
欲があるんだったら必要なものをあげるっていうふうにやればいいんですが
相手もぐるぐる回ってるのに付き合っていれば
例えば自我意識を高めたいと思っている人がいて
その次は今度欲だとか
コロコロコロコロ変わってたら
一体自分は何をやればいいのか
だから適切に対応するんですよ
だから相手といったって
みんなそうでしょうに
人間は一人残らず感情錯乱状態ですよ
だから誰に向かってあなたはいい人
あなたは悪い人と言えないんですよ
今いい人いたのに すぐもう悪いことをやったりするし
だからあなた 本当に私を応援して協力してくれる
またすぐ別に自分の足を引っ張る可能性もあるし
だから人間の性格っていうのは
感情が錯乱状態でぐるぐる回ってるんだから
もういつでも混乱状態ですよ
それに適切に対応するというのはあり得ないんです
できない 人がはっきりと白黒つけているならば
私は怒りだと 言うならば怒りに対処できますよ
誰もそうじゃないでしょ
でも 怒りの塊という人には対処しなくていいんですよ
すぐ死にますからね 大量殺人のかなんとかやるでしょ
もう対応する暇がないんで
すぐもう潰れてるんです
我々はずっともうもう生き続けているのはこの感情錯乱だから
怒りももうすぐ変わっちゃうし
もう欲も変わっちゃうし
だから誰でもそういう混乱状態にいるんですよ
だからもう慈しみという手袋で扱うしかないんです
そのなんか相手の感情に対して何かを当てはめるじゃない
そういうのは慈しみとは言わないという
それは智慧の世界 それはあなた方にできることじゃないんです
お坊さんさえも結構失敗したりする
それはできたのはお釈迦様だけなんです
ぴったしできたのは だから仏教心理を知っている我々もそれをやろうとはしない
ただ慈しみで当たってみる
だからあなた相当馬鹿者だというのは怒りじゃないんですよ
本当に心配して 言っている言葉なんです
心配しないでそんな失礼なこと言わない
そうすると戒律に当たるんだから
私たちの場合は それは言わない
相手は本当に悪くて もう自分にも嫌なことをしてきたったら
黙ってその場を去る だから慈しみでしか我々一般人には対応できない
あるいは一人で瞑想していつでも落ち着いている
世界に何があったっても驚かないと
どちらかです はい  現実的なことなんですけども
娘に翻弄されておりまして
怒りができまして それを落ち着く
落ち着かせるように作って
瞑想っていうとこまではできないんですけれども
2 年間ずっとバトルをやった上で
だんだん自分の体が持たなくなってきましたので
静かにしてる方がいいなというので
落ち着きではないですけども
その入り口ぐらいまでは来たかなと思うんですが
やはり相手の出た出方でまだ騒いで
自分の体と心はやはりいつも安定した状態にいられないですね
それで そういう中で その子供を自分の子供でありながら
寝顔を見た時には涙が出るようなこともあるんですけれども
一旦目が覚めて起きてきて
姿を見て その行為なり言葉なりにやはり動かされて
自分がいつも静密にそれをじっと見てて
慈しんであげるっていうことができないです
歳は  19になりました
なりました  だからこの人間っていうのは
我々計画する通りにならないんですよ
まず 自分では母親としては立派な人間になってほしいという
すごい大きな夢があるんですけど
もう誰もそんな夢にはね
叶わないんですよ だから母親から見れば
全くももう出来の悪い
もうどうしようもない子供で見えちゃうんですよ
出来悪くないんです  そこはダメですよ
だったら怒るはずないでしょうに
それが  出来がすごくいいんだったら
自分がはいはい わかりましただけでしょうに
そうなんですけど 病気っていうか
精神的に脅迫観念ですごいその
そこは人間だから 今言ってること
出来が悪いってことなんですけど
そうですね 病気になってしまうというか
すごい  うん 出来が良ければそうならないんでしょ
その病気に翻弄されちゃうんですね
何でしたっけ？病名は
なんか怖いよ こうなってすごい動けなくなったりとか
力出られなくなったとか
血がかけないとか あと色々で脅迫
お化けが出るとか  だから基本的にはどこかに弱みがあって
それをごまかしてるんですよ
いろんなところで母親として期待するところあるんですよ
ありのままの自分 ありのままの自分を認めなさいと
そうするとホッとするんですよ
人間っていうのは世界で成長するんです
世界の社会の中で 社会の中っていうのは不親切ですから
もうやられたり いろいろ失敗したりあります
そこで家に走って出て
はぁ 場所があるんだと
オアシスがあるんだという
そこでほんのちょっとの時間いて
また世界に出るんで 社会に出るんですよ
家っていうのはそういう場所を作るところなんです
だから母親というのはもう別に何も
まあ今日も失敗したのか
まあいいや もうご飯食べなさいという態度で
そこで子供は自分の失敗話やら
誰かにいじめされたこととか
ガチャガチャそうですか
それで大変です ただ聞いてあげたりとかね
そういう風にこの何でも言ったり
何でも排除できるオアシスなんですね
母親が 現代の母親が理性に悩んでるんですね
くだらない理性に これでもぶつかるんです
だから何か悩み 弱みがあるんですよ
これが隠そうとして激しいんですよ
あまりにもうまくいっちゃうと
そういう強迫観念 なれ上がりとかね
いわゆる言い訳してるんです
社会に出ないために それを世界設定自分がね
だから自分を責める必要ないんで
別に完璧じゃないんだから
人間っていうのはね だからまあ子育てはいろいろ失敗ありますよ
それはどうったことはないんです
でも自分が落ちすぎて
子供には自分がいること
自分の顔を見ることで穏やかな気持ちになるようにということがいいとは思います
もう子供ではありませんけどね
親をいじめたりするならば捨てるしかないんですけど
それはしないんだったら
もうちょっと母親になってあげる
うん 何でも聞いてあげて
まあそうかっていう感じでね
だから自分がまあそんなもんだから
何言うかっていうぐらいでね
言い違いますよっていうことはよくないんです
ということなんです だから嫌なことでもなんだかんだでも
まあ自分の子供言う分はもう聞いていられるでしょ
他人も同じこと言っちゃうともうたまったもんじゃないんですけど
自分の子供ぐらいはね
最後までそのそうできない自分に悩んでるところがあって
それがまた  理性的にならないこと
完璧主義にならないこと
逆に自分が完璧かと自分に聞いてみてください
自分は全然完璧じゃないし
いっぱいもう失敗しているし
なのに何も人生経験ない人がね
そんなのを期待するのは失礼でしょ
そのまんまで認めるということは
もう今今しなくちゃいけない
これ小さい時はこれでダメよと言ってもいいんだけどね
我々は子供が小さい時はそのままで認めるでしょ
もうダメなこと バカなことやってるのに全然もう平気でしょ
教えてあげるんだけど
気持ちは平気でしょ まあ子供だからということでね
なんで大きくなるとそれできんですかね
だからまあそのままに認めるということは必要な条件です
まあそうするとまあゆっくりではまあ若いんだからね
まあ立ち直ると思います
はい どういたしますか
他にございますか  慈しみの心っていうのが
やっぱり落ち着いていないと絶対に出てこないし
育たないものだと思うんですけれども
例えば慈しみっていうのは
落ち着いたりしてて育つということであれば
ヴィパッサナー修行を毎日実践したりとか
そういうこととすごくつながりがあると思うんですけども
それ以外の 例えば本当に慈しみの心を人に持つためには
どういう風に日々を送って
今言ってることは全部忘れることです
全部言ってるのはむちゃくちゃなんです
言ってることは これははっきり言って自分にはフーレットだからわからないでしょ
感情は 私には見えますよ
裏でいる感情は これはやりたくない
わからないという  なんか偽善なことのように感じてしまう
だから犬にもできるんだからね
それぐらいの単純なことなんです
やり方 一応書いてあったんですよ
このスライドの中で 何のこともないんで
そんなのは大胆なことでもなんでもないんですよ
もうこの人々 みんな死んでほしい
ないでしょ 何かもう例えば地震があって
この屋根が潰れちゃうと
みんな怪我して自分だけ逃げたい
自分の期待から見れば
みんな無事逃げればありがたいでしょ
それが慈しみでしょうね
これ常識でしょうね 自分が道路で歩いている時といきなりオートバイが出てきて
車にぶつかっちゃって
オートバイの人が倒れたりする
それは仮定の話ですけど
自分がいいこと邪魔見ろ
あんた赤信号間違ったんだから
思いますか？だからその時もかわいそう
大変やと思うでしょうに
だからなんで慈しみがわからないんですかね
だから犬がしっぽを振るようなぐらいの単純なことなんです
犠牲じゃないんです 今も自分には慈しみの気持ちあるんですよ
ただ ルーレットのように余計ないらん線が入っちゃって
これはもうもつれてるだけ
この心が ただそれだけ
これ犠牲ではないか それは義でしょうに
ヴィパッサナーもする必要あるんだけど
関係ないこと言ってるんです
それはもう無知ですよ
ヴィパッサナーって何なのかわかってる人だったら
絶対そんなことは言わないんです
それ無知なの だから無知やら義やらもう
その気持ちですよ 別に
それから表に出すだけ
だから一本の板なんですけど
いらん線がいっぱい繋ぎてるんだからもう通らない
だから妄想するなよと言ったことと同じなんです
余計な妄想何もなく ただみんな幸せでいれば当たり前のことだと思うぐらいのことです
頭の中でごちゃごちゃ混乱するときは
ずっと生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにとずっと回転させる
それでじーっと静静ときます
だからあの世の話で見ていけばいけないんです
今すでに自分にある感情なんです
それは外へ出してくださいと家にあるんですよ
タンスの中にあるんじゃなくて
外へ出してくださいと
それだけの話です 難しいことではありません
ヴィパッサナーよりはもうはるかに簡単です
ヴィパッサナーっていうのはものすごい違います
ヴィパッサナー瞑想はすごく難しい
もっと育ったらもっと育っていくものだからというような
ことで ヴィパッサナーは智慧の開発だから
道が違うんです だからとにかく言い訳しちゃうとやらないって意味なんです
それは単純なこのいらん感情が混じってるっていうことで
だから悪い例で説明したんですよ
いっぱい もう怒りだけだったらもう何の躊躇
何人でも殺してしまう
だから聞いたら誰でもよかったと言うでしょ
平気でそういう異常な犯罪者たちが
で 捕まって裁判でも反省なんか全然していない
それで弁護士側も困るんだから
強引にもう反省したような形にする
それだけ 反省してないんです
あの宅間なんとかっていうこの子供
この人は全然いまだに別に全然気にしてない
そういう悪い例で説明したんだから
このいい例になってくる
慈悲もそういうふうな感じであれこれと考えるんじゃない
慈悲は善だから あれこれと考えるものはすべて不善なんです
例えばヴィパッサナーでもいくらかやれば慈悲ができるのではないかという考え方は不善であって
悪行為であって良いことじゃないんです
心の法則っていうのは結構危ないんですよ
みんな知ってることと違う
例えば殺してやるぞという人には躊躇が現れたら
どうかな 悪いなという
それは善なんです だったらいいわけじゃないでしょうと思っちゃうと
自分が逮捕されるでしょうと
自分の自己愛が出たっても
それは善です それで殺せなくなっちゃいますから
そういう思考では 慈悲の瞑想するためにはこれこれなければという場合はやらないという結果になるんだからね
不正になるんです だからそんな思考は全部きれいさっぱり忘れて
今自分にあるんだから
今の自分とすでに優しい人間だから
人の幸福を願っている人間だから
それを認めるだけ 認めれば悪いことはできなくなります
なんて言いますか あのあれ
あの手を挙げてなんかの言葉を言うでしょ
あれ 何？何言葉で言うんですか
え？宣誓する それではっきり堂々と宣誓するんです
私は慈悲を心にある優しい人間であると
これ宣誓しちゃうと怒れなくなるんじゃないんですか
慈悲の瞑想っていうのは
それ宣誓するんです 間違わないようにと
それで誰かに何か言われたっても
もうできなくなっちゃうんです
怒ることは それだけです
慈悲の瞑想っていうのは
ただ宣誓するだけ 簡単なことじゃないんです
今の 今のあれで非常に極端な場合を考えますと
私が仮に首切り役になったと
首切り役になったとしても
私の仕事が首切り役になったこととして
仕事にストレスを感じていると考えると
そのストレス解消の方法は
一つはもう首切りということに徹すると
要するに その外での仕事をひたすら切ることだけを考えれば解消できる
もう一つは慈しみの気持ちを持つと
その場合 慈しみの気持ちを持った場合はどうすればいいのかとか
その場合 やっぱりその仕事を辞めた方がいいということになる
何仕事かわからないです
首切り屋  ああ うんうん
はい  怒りが上がって慈しみの心を持つ
首を切るわけにはいかない
できなくなるでしょ あれでストレス溜まるんですよ
だからその場合は仕事を辞めるという
どちらかです  要するに決するか
仕事を辞めるか  やめるか
うん  現実問題として今は考えですけど
例えばその組織 会社とか
そういうところにいてリストラをする立場になった場合にね
俺やめてけど いう時にあの慈悲の心を持つと
そういう人事担当も仕事できなくなる
時々日本でそういうケースあったんです
自分がリストラしなくてはいけないんだけどできなくて
一緒に仕事をした仲間だから自分が会社を辞めたんです
それが正しい  それは立派なことですよ
それも腰抜けでやりたくなければ
もうリストラするしかないんです
だから軍隊の例出しましたから
軍隊でははっきりともうマインドコントロールするでしょ
洗脳するでしょ 心は 明らかに仏教から見れば明らかに悪いことですけど
そういうことをやっちゃうんです
だから我々は普通 別に首切りやってるわけでもないし
泥棒してるわけでもないし
だから我々の場合 一般世間人の世間の場合は簡単ですよ
世界全部見ても泥棒っていうのはそんなにいるわけないでしょうに
たくさん あるいは貧しい...あまりにも貧困で困って
ちょっとちょっと盗んだっていうことはね
これは別に盗みとは取れないし
ベネズエラではまあ貧しい貧困な人は盗んだっても裁かないと法律まで作っているんだから
無罪にしなさいと これはしょうがないと
だから盗みじゃありませんと
あれカトリック教の国ですけど
あのシャベス大統領がかなり立派な人で
ですから まあ普段は泥棒っていうのはいるわけじゃないし
人殺し屋もね そうたくさんいるわけじゃないし
いるんだったら我々もうとっくに死んでるでしょうに
だから我々一般的な人と仕事して平和で生きていきたい人間だから
だから私たちにはストレスなく生きることは意外と簡単という論点なんです
大変な難しいことじゃない
意外と簡単 首切りみたいな例で考えちゃうと
まあすごく厳しい仕事でね
やるかやめるかと  どちらにしても
お釈迦様たちから見ればいいですかね
いえ まあ線画ははっきりしてますよ
首切り屋に決めたら人殺しに決めたんだから
もうどうせ地獄に落ちますよ
覚悟すれば  もうそれは覚悟でやらないと
ではありがとうございます